♪ ♪
>> Bill: DEMOCRATIC HEAVY
HITTERS TURNING UP THE
HYPERBOLIC RHETORIC.
>> THIS IS REALLY DEADLY
EARNEST.
DEMOCRACY IS ON THE BALLOT ALONG
WITH YOUR RIGHT TO CHOOSE ON THE
TO PRIVACY.
>> DEMOCRACY AS WE KNOW IT MAY
NOT SURVIVE IN ARIZONA.
THAT'S NOT AN EXAGGERATION.
THAT'S A FACT.
>> THIS COUNTRY IS ON TRACK TO
REPEAT WHAT HAPPENED IN GERMANY
WHEN IT WAS THE GREATEST
DEMOCRACY GOING, ELECTED
CHANCELLOR WHO THEN CO-OPTED THE
MEDIA.
>> Bill: THAT'S RICH.
SHOULD POLITICIANS TRY TO TURN
DOWN THE HEAT WITH INCIDENTS
LIKE THIS HAPPENING?
THE FBI'S SAID TO BE
INVESTIGATING A SHOOTING IN A
NORTH CAROLINA HOME AT THE
PARENTS OF REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE PAT HERE
AGAIN.
IT HAPPENED LAST MONTH.
A SUSPECT FIRING A SHOT THROUGH
THE WINDOW.
THE CANDIDATES CHILDREN SLEEPING
ONLY A FEW FEET AWAY.
THANKFULLY NO ONE WAS INJURED.
NO REST HAVE BEEN MADE AND THE
CANDIDATE IS SOUNDING OFF ON
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> I RECEIVED VERY CREDIBLE
DEATH THREAT.
THIS WAS FOLLOWED UP BY MY
OPPONENT UTILIZING VERY POOR
JUDGMENT TO ACTUALLY SHOOT AND
ADD OUT IN FRONT OF ONE OF MY
HOMES AND DISPLAY THAT HOME FOR
ALL TO SEE IN THE WORLD.
IN AN ERA OF STEVE SCALISE AND
BRETT KAVANAUGH AND NOW PAUL
PELOSI, MY PARENTS ARE WATCHING
TV AT 11:00 AT NIGHT SITTING IN
THEIR LIVING ROOM AND A BULLET
CRACKED THROUGH THEIR HOME ONLY
20 FEET AWAY FROM WHERE MY KIDS
WERE SLEEPING.
THIS IS POLITICS AT ITS WORST.
>> Bill: HE IS RUNNING FOR A
SEAT ON THE WEST SIDE OF
CHARLOTTE, FAVORED FOR
DEMOCRATS.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT GOES.
TO MY PARTNER, DANA.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T SPENT ENOUGH
TIME TODAY TOGETHER THERE'S MORE
COMING UP.
THAT'S A TEASE.
WHAT ABOUT GOING BACK TO NAZI
GERMANY?
>> Dana: ONCE YOU START
TALKING ABOUT THAT, NOBODY IS
LISTENING.
THE DEMOCRATS SEEM SO UPSET WITH
EVERY OTHER VOTER WHO IS NOT
TAKING THINGS AS SERIOUSLY AS
THEY ARE.
THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
JANUARY 6.
A MAJOR ISSUE.
IT WAS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE BEING
PROSECUTED RIGHT NOW.
EVERYBODY IN THE MEANTIME AS
THEY ARE GOING TO THE BALLOT BOX
ARE LIKE WELL, WE'VE GOT CRIME
AS AN ISSUE.
THE BORDER IS AN ISSUE.
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT ALSO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEY
ARE PAYING THROUGH THEIR NOSE AT
THE PUMP, ALSO FOUND OUT TODAY A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN NEW ENGLAND
FOUND OUT THEIR HEATING BILLS
ARE GOING TO BE 60% HIGHER THAN
THEY WERE LAST YEAR.
ALL OF THIS IS COMING FAST AND
FURIOUS AND THEY ARE MAD AND
SAYING CONGRESS, IF IT CHANGES
FROM A DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY TO A
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY, THAT ALL OF
A SUDDEN IS NAZI GERMANY?
THAT'S A STRETCH.
THE OTHER THING IS, I GUARANTEE
YOU IF THINGS GO THE WAY IT
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE GOING AT
LEAST ESPECIALLY IN THE HOUSE,
WHAT IS PRESIDENT BIDEN GOING TO
SAY THE NEXT DAY?
HE'S GOING TO SAY IT WASN'T AS
BAD AS IT COULD HAVE BEEN AND I
AM SO GREAT OKAY FINE.
BUT THEN HE IS GOOD TO SAY WON'T
MATTER.
BECAUSE I'VE GOT A PEN AND A
PHONE AND I HAVE THE VETO POWER.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO SAY SO HOW IS THAT
TIERNEY?
THAT'S DEMOCRACY.
>> Bill: TO THE ONE ARMED
BANDIT, LISTENING TO THE
HARRIGAN STORY.
REMINDED ME OF A STORY IN
NEW YORK.
>> Judge Jeanine: I WAS
WATCHING I WAS THINKING THERE
WERE TWO ISSUES.
THERE IS THE HYPER POLITICAL
CLIMATE THAT WE ARE LIVING IN
WITH A BULLET GOING THROUGH THE
HOME.
THEN THERE IS A CRIME ISSUE.
I WOULD BET MY BOTTOM DOLLAR THE
PERSON WHO SHOT THAT BULLET
THROUGH THE HOME OF PAT
HARRIGAN'S FAMILY IS SOMEONE
WHO'S GOT A PRIOR CRIMINAL
RECORD.
YOU KNOW.
I THINK IT'S THIS PERFECT STORM
THAT WE'VE GOT OF CHAOS AND
ANARCHY IN THIS COUNTRY WHERE
ANYTHING GOES ANYMORE.
THERE IS NO ONE WHO IS BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE SOLIS JUST GET
UP AND DO WHEN OUR GUT INSTINCTS
TELL US TO DO.
YOU KNOW, DANA, I WAS THINKING
AS YOU WERE SPEAKING.
WILL JOE BIDEN EXCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THIS ELECTION?
WILL HE BE SOMEONE WHO SAYS YOU
KNOW WHAT, I ACCEPTED.
WILL HE SAY I TOOK A
SHELLACKING?
MAYBE I WAS ON THE WRONG COURSE.
THESE PEOPLE, ALL OF THEM LIKE
CHICKEN LITTLE.
THE SKY IS FALLING.
NAZI GERMANY.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
FOR ANYONE WHO IS A JEW, THAT'S
THE WORST THING YOU CAN SAY.
HOW CAN YOU COMPARE THE POLITICS
OF TODAY TO THAT HORRIFIC
ELIMINATION OF JEWS IN EUROPE
DURING WORLD WAR II?
>> Bill: FAIR POINT.
A LOT OF JEWS IN NEW YORK ARE
GOING FOR LEE ZELDIN.
WATCHING THAT STORY.
SEE HOW IT TURNS OUT.
JESSE, WILL YOU ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THIS ELECTION?
>> Jesse: YEAH BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO BE A BLOWOUT.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE CLOSE
ENOUGH TO QUESTION.
I AM AN AMATEUR HISTORIAN.
THERE WAS ONE PARTY THAT
ENSLAVED A RACE AND STARTED A
CIVIL WAR AND PUT ANOTHER RACE
IN INTERNMENT CAMPS, SENSORS
SPEECH, RATES HOMES, PLANS
EVIDENCE, SENSORS SPEECH,
ACCUSES HIM OF THE PEOPLE BEING
COCKROACHES.
I CAN CALL THE DEMOCRATS NAZIS
BUT I WON'T BECAUSE I CHOOSE TO
SHOW LITTLE BIT MORE RESTRAINT.
I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
ACCUSE US OF NEXT.
MANHATTAN IS NOT UNDERWATER,
AL GORE.
BLACKS ARE NOT BACK IN CHAINS,
JOE BIDEN.
WE ARE STILL GOING TO HAVE
VOTING, BARACK OBAMA, AND WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE NAZIS NEXT YEAR.
IT IS LIKE THE BOY WHO CRIED
WOLF AND THEN HE CRIED DINOSAUR
THEN HE CRIED LOCH NESS MONSTER.
WHAT'S WORSE THAN BEING AN
UNDERWATER SLAVE-OWNING NAZI?
I'VE A FEELING WE ARE GOING TO
FIND OUT.
>> Bill: WE SHALL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN APPARENTLY ON
THE TARMAC.
HE'S CAMPAIGNING IN SOME
DISTRICTS YOU WOULDN'T EXPECT.
HE SAID WE ARE GOING TO WIN THIS
TIME.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT OUR
CHANCES.
[LAUGHTER]
SORRY.
>> Jesse: OH, THAT'S REALLY
WHAT HE SAID?
YOU GOT ME.
>> Bill: HAROLD, WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT GOING BACK TO 1941?
>> Harold: I DON'T WANT TO.
MY PRAYERS GO OUT TO THIS YOUNG
CANDIDATE NORTH CAROLINA AND I
HOPE WE ALL, WE'LL HAVE COME
EVERYBODY IN POLITICS HAS
CONDEMNED THIS AND WE'VE GOTTEN
TO A POINT UNFORTUNATELY IN
WHICH EVERYONE HAS REMARKED
ABOUT WHERE THE WAY YOU
INSTIGATE TURNOUT FOR YOUR OWN
PARTY IS TO PERSONALLY CASTIGATE
THE OTHER SIDE.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT HOW YOUR IDEAS ARE BETTER
AND HOW THE OPPONENTS IDEAS
WOULD NOT MAKE THE COUNTRY
STRONGER AND SAFER AND HEALTHIER
AND MORE WHOLE.
TODAY WE SAY THAT AND WE SAY THE
MOST AWFUL PERSONAL THINGS ABOUT
A PERSON YOU'RE RUNNING AGAINST.
IT UNDERCUTS THE WHOLE PURPOSE
OF SERVING AND WORKING WITH THEM
BECAUSE ONCE THE ELECTION IS
OVER, HE WILL TO COME TOGETHER.
SAYING WE GOT BEAT.
WE GOT TO WORK TOGETHER.
CLINTON DID IT.
OTHER PRESIDENTS HAVE HAD TO DO
IT INCLUDING PRESIDENT OBAMA,
AND THEY DID.
SOME WOULD ARGUE THAT PERHAPS
DIVIDED GOVERNMENT MAKES IT
BETTER FOR THINGS TO GET DONE.
I'M NOT NECESSARILY BELIEVING
DEMOCRATS ARE BELIEVING THAT'S
THE CASE THIS GO AROUND BUT ONE
THING IS FOR CERTAIN.
IF REPUBLICANS GET THE MAJORITY,
THERE WILL BE SOME PEOPLE I
FERVENTLY DISAGREE WITH.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF PEOPLE I
HOPE MY PARTY CAN FERVENTLY WORK
WITH.
I HOPE THE RHETORIC, WHATEVER
HAPPENS NEXT TUESDAY OR
WEDNESDAY IF WE HAVE RUNOFFS,
WHEN IT COMES DOWN EVERYONE HAS
TO MAKE A COMMITMENT AND SAY TO
THE COUNTRY.
JESSE, DANA, BILL, ONE ARM.
WE MAY DIFFER ON THINGS THAT WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER.
OTHERWISE WERE NOT GOING TO
SOLVE IT.
PUT DOWN THE WEAPONS IF YOU
DISAGREE WITH SOMEBODY.
THIS IS NOT A TIME TO BE KNIFING